Even heroes make terrible mistakes from time
to time: in fact, in some movies, they're
hardly heroes at all.
With that in mind, here's a look at some of
the more glaring good guy misfires in movie
history.
There’s one thing you have to give to Daniel
Hillard: he loves his kids.
“I need to be with my children.
And I’ll do anything.”
Unfortunately, that didn’t make him a good
husband, and when his marriage broke up, the
out of work actor lost custody of his children
until he could get steady work and a place
to live.
It’s a little harsh, but also, “job”
and “home” are a couple of pretty low
bars to clear for someone who’s supposed
to be raising three children.
And yet, when Daniel’s life inevitably crumbles
around him, he decides that it’s a better
idea to create a false identity, dupe his
ex-wife into hiring him as a nanny to his
own children, and then try to sabotage her
new relationship.
Whether or not you buy into Mrs. Doubtfire's
heartwarming charm, that is straight up sociopathic
behavior.
At best, he’s a liar, and at worst, dragging
your children into a complicated web of lies
and deception is the sort of thing that’s
going to require years of therapy before they
can even begin to trust again.
Daniel has decent enough goals, but he betrays
the trust of his entire family, and unquestionably
proves that his ex-wife was right about everything.
It's easy to forget that in 2002’s horror
classic The Ring, Rachel Keller was a journalist
chasing a lead tied to the suspicious death
of her niece.
It’s that misguided search for the juicy
story that leads her to Samara's deadly tape,
and it's her tragic misunderstanding of the
situation that leads her to "help" the accursed
child.
Needless to say, that was a bad idea.
Not only does she unleash Samara’s spirit
and cause yet another death, she also makes
multiple copies of the tape.
Again, she’s got the noble goal of saving
her son, but with two tapes out there, she’s
also condemning unknown numbers of people
to die in the future.
And the worst part?
She didn’t even get to file her story.
If you’ve seen Avengers: Age of Ultron,
you already know that Bruce Banner and Tony
Stark’s attempt at creating a helpful artificial
intelligence wound up going bad.
In an act of astonishing hubris, these two
geniuses put their new creation in charge
of Tony’s gadget factory and S.H.I.E.L.D.
itself, and then went to a party without bothering
to check and see if anything had gone wrong.
The result was Ultron, a killer robot who
destroyed Sokovia in what was undoubtedly
the Marvel Cinematic Universe’s most devastating
act of destruction… at least until Thanos
showed up.
While Banner responded to the incident by
flying off to space and spending two years
as a big green gladiator (hey, it was actually
cheaper than therapy), Tony just kept making
things worse.
His guilt over Sokovia led to the registration
act that prompted his Civil War with Captain
America, which in turn left Earth’s heroes
divided when Thanos arrived with the Infinity
Stones.
Tony’s still out there trying to fix things,
but given his track record over the past few
years, maybe he should just focus on making
a new phone.
Stars Wars fans the world over would have
you believe that Obi-Wan Kenobi is one of
the wisest characters in a galaxy far, far
away, but let’s be honest with each other.
Obi-Wan pretty much messes up everything,
all the time.
In Star Wars Episode 1: The Phantom Menace,
Young Obi-Wan almost single-handedly destroys
the Jedi when he demands, against the better
judgement of Yoda and pretty much every member
of the Jedi Council, to train Anakin Skywalker.
Spoiler warning, but that didn’t work out
so well for him, or any of the younglings
at Jedi School, or the people of Alderaan,
or… well, you get the idea.
Jump ahead to A New Hope, and you’ll see
Obi-Wan doesn't really fare much better by
keeping the identity of Luke Skywalker's father
a secret.
If nothing else, knowing his full story from
the start of things could've saved him from
passionately kissing his own sister.
Grandpa Joe is unquestionably set up as Charlie
Bucket's personal hero in 1971's Willy Wonka
and the Chocolate Factory.
He’s the first person Charlie runs to after
winning the contest, and he's also Charlie's
plus-one on their fateful tour of the unhinged
candy tycoon's confection factory.
Before we get into that psychedelic tour,
though, let's revisit the fact that Grandpa
Joe is bedridden when the film begins.
He even claims to be incapable of working,
thus leaving his family to live in utter poverty,
until Charlie comes charging through the door
with a ticket to unlimited chocolate.
The second that happens, Grandpa Joe is suddenly
and suspiciously capable of dancing around
the one-room hovel where he’s been living
rent-free for who knows how long.
On the tour, it's Joe who encourages Charlie
to to steal some of that fizzy-lifting drink,
which nearly leads them both to being diced
up by the fan in the ceiling vent and almost
disqualifies Charlie from inheriting Wonka's
factory.
It’s always nice to spend some time with
your grandparents, but maybe Charlie would
be better off not hanging out with a geriatric,
kleptomaniac con man.
On paper, Scott Pilgrim's tale is in fact
a romantic epic full of 8-bit flair.
Edgar Wright's stylish blend of action, comedy
and romance makes Scott Pilgrim vs. the World
a one-of-a-kind cinematic experience, so much
so that it's easy to forget that Scott himself
is a bit of a scumbag.
Sure, it's a bummer that he's forced to fight
and defeat all eight of Ramona Flowers' evil
exes in order to prove his love, but let's
not forget that the twenty-something Scott
was dating naïve high-schooler Knives Chau
the whole time he was pursuing Ramona.
Though Scott atones for his actions late in
the film, he never really does right by Knives,
ultimately leaving her broken-hearted and
treading water in his oh-so romantic, self-serving
wake.
In Shaun of the Dead, Simon Pegg might just
be playing the ultimate slacker hero.
He works at a low-level electronics store,
he can't remember his mother's birthday, he
hangs out with his weed-dealing bestie way
too much, and he can't seem to commit to his
longtime girlfriend Liz.
When the dead walk and threaten to end humanity,
Shaun finally steps up and sets out to save
the lives of everyone he loves by taking them
to his favorite pub and having a drink while
things blow over.
Day drinking during the apocalypse might sound
like a good idea, but in Shaun’s case, it’s
an absolute disaster.
Even setting aside the perilous road to get
to the Winchester, matters get out of hand
quickly once Shaun and his crew find their
way inside and people start to die.
Not Shaun, though.
He somehow finds a way to safety, and even
manages to save Liz.
Still, Shaun will be forced to live the rest
of his life with the blood of those fallen
companions on his hands, giving a whole new
meaning to the phrase, "You've got red on
you."
Here's a few pointers for all of the lovers
out there who can't quite tell whether or
not that certain someone you've just met is
"the one."
If you wake up in the middle of the night
and find them in your room, uninvited and
watching you sleep, it's time to end that
relationship.
If they break up with you in the middle of
the woods and leave you there crying and alone
rather than giving you a ride home, you should
stay broken up.
If they're overprotective to the point of
threatening your friends just because they're
talking to you, you might want to take some
space.
If they ever almost kill you because they
really, really like the taste of your blood,
you should probably seek out the authorities.
And for Pete's sake, if they turn to you after
just a few dates and declare, "You are my
life now," just go ahead and get a restraining
order.
Since Twilight hit theaters in 2008, some
of Edward Cullen’s sparkly sheen has lost
its luster, and people are starting to see
that he was really just an undead creep, and
that Bella's life would've been totally fine
if he had just left her alone.
Being a superhero means making enemies, and
making enemies means the people you love will
always be in peril.
That's the one lesson Peter Parker learns
the hard way in The Amazing Spider-Man 2,
and he learns it at the expense of his girlfriend
Gwen Stacy.
Of course, Peter didn't have to learn that
lesson at all, because he had someone explicitly
lay out the the stakes of being a hero.
Gwen's father, Police Captain George Stacy,
died while saving Spider-Man's life.
With his dying words, he had one simple request:
that Peter not date his daughter, so she'd
never be the target of one of Spider-Man's
enemies.
Alas, Peter completely ignores it in the sequel,
so it should come as no surprise that Gwen
is eventually taken hostage by the bad guys,
and pays for Peter’s heroics with her life.
If only someone had warned him this exact
thing would happen!
Oh, wait.